so
people are getting pretty worried about
this y2k problem huh
no they fixed that 900 years ago
so this is the year 3000 that would be a
thousand years ago bender
if you're going to be an [ __ ] and
heckle at least get your facts straight
also this episode aired december 19 1999
this joke was in reference to what would
potentially transpire a couple of weeks
later so let me be that [ __ ] and
remind you the millennium technically
didn't until december 31st 2000.
anyway i'm walking to work this morning
we could question how any of this works
and just buy into it but i can't stop
wondering
how his voice is projecting from
underwater through glass that should
sound super gargly
we're heading straight for those trees
yeah yeah relax
trees down at some point everyone had
the tree activation deactivation class
otherwise clearing these trees would be
a universal struggle so why did fry not
get a chance to take ski tree 101
lick my frozen metal ass a surprising
insult considering any human that would
lick his ass would immediately be stuck
to his robot body and bender really just
wants to be left alone
quatmus christmas you know x-m-a-s
oh you mean x-mas and they already knew
that's what he meant
the term christmas would be part of
their history not to mention he said a
word with the mass at the end at this
time of year
[ __ ] pretentious pronunciation games
i should go make a gif about it and if
you don't think it's pronounced jiff
please see what alex trebek thinks trust
the trebek
and now we ponder why a man who loves to
expose his skin to the elements would
have tan lines
everything's changed that's not true but
for fry everything has changed and this
is the dumbest thing leela has ever said
to him
also what's the point of the blade still
being on the axe if it has the laser
option this is like having a steering
wheel in a self-driving car
they've got a bag covering the root of
the tree but when we saw leela laser the
tree she cut the trunk
look i'm just trying to get to the root
of the problem here there is only one x
on the floor
and that is just dumb here i am whining
like a pig while all along leela was as
lonely as a frog
fry has clearly never been to a frog's
birthday party they are literally
hopping get it it's a joke
i made a funny earthlings do not yet
know the meaning of suffering
news anchor jokes simply get down in
your claws and do the apology dance
this is a sin for the shame i will
suffer when performing this dance the
next time i'm in the dog house
we have stockings we have no stockings
so
earlier amy was hanging xmas bulbs on
the string of lights i almost pointed it
out because it seems ridiculous but then
i thought perhaps it was a new tradition
but now she's jabbing them into the bark
of the palm tree
and i can't help but wonder what the
hell any of it means due to a
programming error
santa's standards were set too high and
he invariably judges everyone to be
naughty
if he catches you after dark he'll chop
off your head
okay but i feel like we're skipping over
why the programmer created a kill
setting in this robot in the first
place i'm sorry timmy tim seems we ran
out early tonight but why did bender get
so many bowls
sure we want to blame bender for being
an [ __ ] but
really it's the system we should be
angry with because clearly there are no
restrictions
hold on a second earlier professor nikki
nipples said
pine trees have been extinct for 800
years fry
gone the way of the poodle so what is
that i cried for 12 seconds over the
extinction of the poodle and for what
i just want to point out that this
creature's poops are the same shape as
its noggin noodle
and now we know where the poop comes out
i'll take the 500 lizards
no wait yes no yes
yes yes indecisive customers two minutes
before closing time on
xmas [ __ ] eve hi there
leela x machina you've been very naughty
frying leela how would robot santa know
fry's name
he's a time traveler robot santa was
valedictorian at the stormtrooper school
of aiming at things
i'm going to shove coal so far up your
stocking you'll be coughing up diamonds
and this is a bad thing because
goodbye fry goodbye leela hey look we're
under the mistletoe
we're about to die so we might as well
get freaky cliche
your mistletoe is no match for my tow
missile
nice one-liner but santa wouldn't be
able to see the mistletoe from here let
alone hear fry
i'm the fourth day of xmas i stole from
that lady
four family photos three jaws of pennies
good thing the lady had the correct
number of each of these items or we
wouldn't have been able to hear the
robot sing this song
oh wait that actually would have been a
better option oh thank you
sheesh does pennywise just have to be in
everything these days
but i sold my hair to a wig maker so i
could buy a set of combs for hermes
fry went out to get a gift a bit ago and
everyone freaked out because it was
santa sleigh time so when did anyone
have time to cut their hair give it to a
wig maker and
have the wig maker make a wig for
zoidberg sweet manatee of galilee
is on the roof well if santa can come in
the house as well then
not being on the streets is clearly not
the only rule you have to follow
why does anyone stay in new new york on
xmas eve if there's this high a
probability of being slaughtered
how did santa get his entire sleigh and
reindeer duo down the chimney along with
him
and don't you dare say it's because of
the magic of xmas
you've all been very naughty very
naughty indeed
i don't know they can't be that naughty
if they extinguish the raging fire so
you'd avoid being burned
except you dr zoidberg this is for you
santa excludes zoidberg from the naughty
list but earlier professor farnsworth
said
due to a programming error santa's
standards were set too high
and he invariably judges everyone to be
naughty
so why would zoidberg be given a present
[Music]
this works merry xmas everyone
farnsworth festival flashing flesh for
friends feels flagrant
christmas is ruined do you hear the ding
in your head when you watch movie
i hear it all the damn time especially
around the holidays and i'm done hiding
my damn dings i'm going to wear them
proudly like a goddamn youtube grinch if
you want to do the same you can grab
this limited edition monstrosity from
our store
mary dingles everyone ladies and
gentlemen
conan o'brien's head
[Music]
i have lots of letters for you hello
birdie
polly want a cracker polly wants your
mom a sweet ass
[Music]
you're lonely and i'm lonely but
together
we're lonely together that doesn't make
sense hi
georgie